so rushdown character yep and there's
lots of parts and there's lots of farts
somebody in the twitch chat earlier when
I was that when I was reading it earlier
they're like oh barrage o cracked a dojo
window that's good that's good
little unknown fact a majority of the
farts you will hear are from Thailand
sound this is a boat ride show stream so
I can be I'm gonna be gross but I can
I did ask sound if they would let me
record a real one yeah they never happen
solstar was normal like I said he's a
kung fu master and he has a lot of fast
strikes a lot of compost starters he has
a lot of strings they're like you know
four or five hits some pretty good pop
ups and there's a lot of like low and
overheads it is removalist he's got a
quick overhead and then he has a really
interesting stripe that leads to a graph
he has this overhead that leads to a
graph and then he has a low that leads
to the same kind of graph and the graph
changes depending on his variation so
this is dragon's breath so he has the
fire can you do this run because it
makes me giggle
golly run Charlie got absolutely he also
has the unique ability to cancel this
for a move by doing back back and he can
stop it oh so you know that move has a
lot of applications
so that's he also has really good range
on the sona's pokes cuz he's a pretty
big guy a big range on this uppercut and
his jump attacks are some of my
favorites in the game he's got a belly
bash
um his throat is a tribute to Dudley
Alliance
does that used to be one of his
fatalities right yeah one of the
fatalities so real quick so this is just
we can talk about this this is the
dragon's breath yes regular face but all
the movies got over still basic yeah
these are just the basic normals so his
common moves are you start off with the
mkd a tumble kicks the really fast
overhead special move DX wins a third
one and it starts this overhead so like
I said you guys a lot of low attacks and
you can kind of use this as an overhead
like you can do you know a string little
low on it and then go straight into the
overhead it's just a general really
quick overhead move to use its general
like dis normal pokes or slow side like
they're 1011 frames or most of the jabs
is down one is the six level one but
it's like minus four so he doesn't have
a lot of the way just poke ability but
he has just a bunch of options that are
coming at you so you have to know which
way to go but generally if you're ready
for you can help Logan and his folks
might be slow but they have really good
range so it's kind of balanced out on
our common special move he has is this
chunk of punch it's kind of a combo
under like you just do a special
movement this all comes out you can use
that to end combos so you can use the X
version has armor so that's a pretty
good wakeup attack it's also a high but
but that move the safe pump block so
essentially you can use it to to injure
strings and it'll be it'll be safe but
it's a high so they can know it's coming
right now there's a wake up attack it's
a fun walk but if they predict it they
can dunk it alive
she also has eight fart how far is a
combo starter its if it hits they go
into the stun cuz it smells so bad it's
a combo and the fart is also a pressure
tool unblock the fart is advantage and
you can do like a frame trap you can go
for is down one or any others are fast
moves and you gotta kind of respect his
pressure but Bart frame trap fart traps
you got the part the catch is the fart
is kind of a slower move so if he does
like a string into it you can usually
interrupt it with armor like so you can
poke out there's a bunch of the block
strings that you can do into the fart so
the guests will be are you gonna do the
fart or not do the farting farts yeah
they're always when you're fighting a
fat man always look out for the first
the e^x fart is significantly faster and
actually lingers yeah that's the crop
duster and it's kind of like a very
smelly sub-zero ice floe you can leave
it out or you can have it there oh the
gas yeah cotton the gas he also has a
sumo oh the stop it's a pretty quick
unblockable stop see it's decent damage
with a DX one is even a little bit more
damage so you know you can do stuff like
you can have the far plot out and while
they're dealing of that they're gonna
have to jump because of the the fart and
then um you know you can't iron I'm
gonna say that in my life I never
thought I'd be live on a stream talking
about a video game about the technical
aspects of farming yeah yeah you put the
fart out and have to jump and if you
listen close there's a lot of different
sounding parts here too
oh yes he has a chance to fart on almost
all actions and there are many and many
different fart sounds and if you let him
just idle for a little while he's
squeaks one out as well yeah so those
are kind of his cone moves and I leave
in the noon of the belly bag oh that's
right the belly batches are a really
good kind of mid-range moves very quick
it covers a lot of range so you can do
that x1 has armor and then that's the
bump and thump the bump and up first
Koopa and then dump genius alright so
now let's look at dragon's breath well
we're not getting fired for this we're
saying fart a lot I mean it's the
gerotor so dragon's breath is all about
flame breath like he has this kind of
key move which you can use in the
mid-range it's an anti-air it's a combo
ender and the X version is really
interesting it lingers and then actually
travels forward so you can do run up and
throw or run up and do your mix up and
it kind of contains the opponent in fact
you could do X fart and then ignite the
farm the opponent will actually pop up I
gotta watch scream can they see that oh
my goodness so that's like realistic
yeah that's very real it's very
realistic kiddy the fire moves that I'm
gonna show can ignite the farm okay so
you know just throw a couple of those
out from time to time to write up that
fart on fire he also has an anti-air
flame move which is a pretty good
anti-air and the X person doesn't a big
chunk of damage it hasn't even bigger
netbox
and of course you could set that up yeah
the farts Evan lastly she has a ground
fire which is kind of like Aaron blacks
caltrops sure it does damage over time
as they're in it and you'll have a lot
of setups like you could have the fart
out and then they're trying to avoid it
then you put the flames out and it'll
ignite the fart if they're near it and
if not they might walk into the dot and
the x1 is actually really strong it's a
pop-up ignites it with this bottle and
then you can go for a jumbo combo well
what would you say
stylistically as a player dragon's
breath it would be suited to UM it's a
little bit of like safer establish
combos and there's a lot of things are
following that fireball we go out it's
like get in on people quickly and you
can't have more than one ground flame
out at a time right I'll show that it
should give you the fire setup you were
doing the other day Mikaela you're like
firing and then do the stomp was it
sound like that you were doing fun full
screen shot again that okay cool so
that's kind of dragon's breath it's
arguably the most simple of them but
like polo said it has really high
damaging combos because the pop-ups and
some pretty cool snaps at the fire my
favorite thing only try my combo I have
a couple for this may be my fear I love
the art design on this move I think it
looks awesome back is so awesome yeah
you can do sort of that and then like
and then like oh I've missed that part
but yeah you can like you farts in the
middle of comrades and things like that
yeah Tyler did Pat it with let me try
and see if I can get it yeah all right
what are we looking at next next up is
drunken master who is really really
interesting
all right basically if he gains the
ability to take a drink and when you
take a drink it enhances some of his
moves and it actually gives them brand
new moves and there's three levels to
drink level one drunk and you can see
his little flats will start glowing and
his bodily the vision will change we'll
get to that
so level one drunk then there's level to
drunk at level three drop now the
catches once you drink there's a
10-second count now after the ten
seconds borracho will vomit
I like how it like is idle animation
even gets mortis
whether you're drunken and starts to
stumble and that leaves a moment now the
balance to this is as long as he keeps
drinking he won't
he will not pop it keep it up you're not
gonna have the hangover so the idea is
you want to stay drunk and then keep
staying drunk to help that a bunch of
his moves he can cancel into drinking so
example his throat he can choose to hit
it early and get drunk at the full
damage but but now you're going for an
ax blood will set up into you got a
drink back the ground power you can get
drunk drink drink how do you cancel the
throw it's just you just do the down
down what is that you've got for drunk
and you do that and there's the move
those will show you the moves that you
can do this okay so like Paulo said
you're giving up kind of your advantage
and your damage to continuously stay
drunk because you don't want to go into
the puke stage and you want to keep the
enhanced moves you get and he does have
some moves though that will get enhanced
by drunk so why don't you show that okay
the non-drunk moves all right so if your
level one drunk you get access to the
fancy dough yeah sumo so it makes sense
that he has a sumo headbutt and the ex1
is a great move it's almost full screen
and it was a huge chunk of damage she
also gains access to these multi punches
which is kind of another really good
combo ender and then he has these
twirling punches which level up at the
goods drum you see here level one drunk
he just kind of doesn't have a spin
punch level to drop it spends a little
bit more bubble-free drunk is the full
super drunk punch and get super drunk
punch versions of that yeah there's six
different moves depending on a drunk you
are
how much meter you want to spend Bend
there then he also has a stance he can
go to where he goes into this little
sexy pose sexy poem and from there he
can roll forward or back spinning low
attack anyhow
oh man it's gotta be has an uppercut
that pops you up now let's see what what
about the about the spit oh how could
you forget about that one movement you
don't even have to be drunk to do he has
is his puke and it's kind of a mid-range
boom that's kind of decent at this range
but the drunker he gets the better the
move gets if you're level 3 all screen
protector now what happens if you've
never in your room if you meet a brick
there jig feel goes straight to level 35
forgot so thanks for your money yeah so
ever here so if you want to use the bar
you can see hop tipsy is they'll go
straight to level 30 ronk cool yeah
again Paulo players for drunken after
more of a technical style you think yeah
I think a lot of it is going to be
you're gonna have to know to confirm
into you definite know much time you
have left on your drunk and then be able
to hit the firm stuff into a movie that
can't seem to train
illustrator is that you can be the
middle of your combo and if your timers
up you're gonna puke me to get a get
punished or puke your thumbs in that
early or you're gonna be trying to just
do setups so what you're telling me is
puke is full combo punishment it's in
the state of how many drinks you've
taken so if it's just one drink and your
stuff falling a little bit but if you've
been keeping it up for a while and you
eventually do puke it's gonna be longer
when he drinks his stamina bar refills
oh yeah so if he's low on stamina
he's always dripping it completely
refills yeah pressure and I think at
this point we'll look at this x-ray
because it's one of the most interesting
in the game so then like after a combo
breaker go ahead and drink yes of course
the drink has recovery so scorpion good
teleport if he reads it so it's a big
guessing game you gotta find your gaps
if you're not real just find your gap
the probably the best options try to go
for a throw and capture the filling
sneaky drinker so it's x-ray although
for fullscreen he pukes on the ground
that's the star and the cool thing is
you can actually hold it consists of
cute it's unblockable
so there are all kinds of setups you can
use knowing gets unblockable the catch
is unlike most x-rays it does not break
armored yeah so a lot of times you're
gonna go for a pizza and then the guys
go around or sometimes talk about
depending on something you have to do
but mix it up everyone's right so if you
want learn if you read that someone's
doing a lot of delayed wake-ups and you
you can puke on top of that right yeah
okay so I think we've got everything for
drunken master yeah I think a lot of the
mobile part and whenever you cancel into
it there's no like strength they cancel
you to combo ungrounded but because it
because it a slow start this part so you
have to find like pop-up ways so it's
not something you just gobble it apart
like just up any ground thing or any
kind of opening yeah same thing with
block strings we're all under blotches
in the building parts you can feel the
either armor out of it or a lot of
things are just build a program or jump
over it like do a jump like rush in
combos I would say you can generally
think of as regular fart is pressure you
don't expect to hit it yeah yes far is
your combo ex starter awesome so and
then last we have my favorite Bartitsu
this one this one could bring Magners
back for some people from yes right now
those are really the plate uh the 3d
games remember borracho its back and
kids back yeah at this time no it's not
a free throw this time bart's it's you
uh he uses this cake and it changes a
bunch of his normals he gets pretty
decent amount of new attacks and even
gets a new some new local pokes and a
new uppercut this is one longest range
downpours in the game so it's pretty
much between him and Trevor yeah and
Leatherface I got a great uppercut and
then he gets some really cool new
special moves he gets this move which
brings them into the tree stands them so
you know you can in your combos
and then rinsed and he gets the flying
thing the move the he talked Liu Kang
you know 20 years ago to the beat Shang
Tsung except he has to use a key version
he gains the drunken fist he swings it
around and just like uh it's a high but
this one pops up he gains very limber
for being kind of a three move he gains
the spin move which is multiple hits
it's great for breaking armor it's
probably you know one of the easiest in
the game needs to break armor in the x1
adds an extra little pot yeah which the
bullet can interrupt but but you know if
you read them wake up that's really good
damage and I'll okay yeah it means the
looking so regular there does a really
good damage and you can meet her permit
to combo starter right it's it's one of
the time to meter brings where you do it
you see that it hits then you can mash
it and they blocked it you don't have to
do it but the Moose punishable but you
didn't use a bar let me show a little a
little magic that I have you might I'm
gonna take three chances out if I miss
it we're describe think you're gonna get
it I think you'll get one warm up and
then you'll be good here we go I'm
nervous
okay we're talking one more time going
and I'm going to get this I'm gonna get
this folks get some popcorn it's gonna
be away are you gonna look at the move
list no you always do this and it's
never wrong you did that - yeah it's
perfectly oh man this is not boding well
for the compact fight today all right
see something I always look at the
control districts right there we go
that's pretty good right yeah that was
really good Paulo on a scale from one to
ten that was a